5 signs of vitamin D deficiency and how
to get more vitamin D frequent bone and
muscle pains feeling tired and low
energy levels frequent infections like
colds and flu mood swings and depression
and wounds that take a long time to heal
vitamin D is a crucial element our body
needs to maintain strong bones a healthy
immune system and a good mood getting 15
to 30 minutes of sun exposure daily
preferably during midday is the best way
to get more vitamin D dietary sources
include fatty fish like salmon mackerel
and sardines along with 45 dairy
products eggs and mushrooms if you are
experiencing bone and muscle pain due to
vitamin D deficiency it is advised to
get Vitamin D supplements for a month to
restore your vitamin D levels to normal
remember stay curious and stay healthy